The Last of Us Resident Evil Super Mario
I'm taking a look at injuries from video
games set everywhere from a zombie
apocalypse to the Mushroom Kingdom huge
thanks to nordvpn for sponsoring this
video
all Mortal Kombat throwback all the
graphics on this are insane okay we have
a torso splitter here absolutely
decimating the vertebral and spinal
column as well as the retroperitoneal
and the peritoneum this is a problem not
good for Scorpion here and I I feel for
him being a Scorpio myself
oh what are those eyeballs fatality are
those eyeballs or testicles are those
variables or testicles
oh okay so we have a knife to the chest
left side of the chest which is
unfortunate you have the heart there the
aorta lots of vital structures if it
hits the lung we're only getting a
pneumothorax there a collapsed lung
which you can re-inflate
oh that's a problem that that's a
career-ending fatality okay windpipe
trachea removal never seen a black and
trachea like that it must have been a
very heavy smoker wow oh oh my God okay
so we have a small intestine just kind
of hanging out here lots of bleeding so
for this you got to open a patient Up
full laparoscopic procedure not
laparoscopic
laparotomy not laparoscopically
oh why did he just fall apart as a being
he didn't even fall from that high I
actually see most of the organs except
the heart
what a heartless son of a gun
oh okay so that's not a comfortable
position to be in you're having a lot of
hyperextension of the spine especially
in the thoracic area that's known to
have a little bit of a kyphotic or
flexed curve so you're going to be
putting a lot of pressure on the nerves
that come out of the spine
oh okay we're getting uh an
intra-abdominal incision of some sort oh
oh and the skeleton was fully deboned
never seen it happen this way
I mean there has to be a plague of some
sort because this is Resident Evil
there's some bleeding maybe it's a
coagulation disorder
okay you got bit you got bit
two fingers God metacarpals destroyed
all right you gotta tamponade that
bleeding right away you gotta wrap it up
in something well I mean obviously get
away get to Safety First no
hey bro the thing just bit off two of
your fingers you're telling it to stay
back like you're giving it an order that
it would legally comply with
oh that's one of the most painful
injuries getting a bow or a stabbing
directly into the thigh the quad muscle
the femurs there that's just a lot of
pain have you ever had someone roll out
your IT band on the side of your thigh
that hurts now imagine a knife digging
into that or a dirty bow or whatever
this is
now that you got hit in the face it's
kind of over you need chest compression
let's call for help
okay see I wouldn't take this out so
quickly unless you have something ready
to wrap around the womb why because as
soon as you take that thing out you're
gonna get massive arterial bleeding
remember arteries are a high pressure
circulatory system that means every time
the heart beats there's a lot of
pressure and the arteries are able to
withstand that because they have a
muscular layer veins don't have that
through a thin wall so because that high
pressure you can get a ton of blood just
splurting out
oh and you're missing fingers and a part
of your arm how is it stop bleeding this
is so unrealistic Resident Evil you're
unrealist
s
where did my man just get fresh gauze
from in the forest 10 years as a
physician I've never been able to apply
gauze this perfectly my guy is bleeding
out from legs and arms and he's still
applying it perfectly
what
drinking blood will disrupt your GI
system this is why when people want to
have a bloody nose they want to tilt
their head back we say no Do It Forward
because if you start swallowing all that
blood you will either vomit or have
massive diarrhea and or constipation can
I say indoor constipation because uh
blood has a high iron content and if you
consume a lot of iron it can cause
constipation but Blood also acts as a
cathartic so it will make you have
diarrhea so depending on which one of
those variables bother your body more
you will have that as the end result
back to the video games in just a second
but first I want to talk to you about
nordvpn a service that protects your
internet connection and privacy online
here's how it works nordvpn creates an
encrypted tunnel for your data protects
your online identity by hiding your IP
address and allows you to use public
Wi-Fi hotspots safely they also give you
access to content from anywhere for
example say you're in a country that
doesn't have a streaming download option
for Resident Evil Village well if you
use nordvpn you could set your location
to a country that does have access to it
so you you can download and play as much
as you want Nord is not just a simple
VPN though but also offers threat
protection a malware blocker without
additional costs for a limited time with
5500 servers across 59 different
countries you won't have any trouble
finding one near you for the fastest
connection or one far away from you to
give you access to your shows movies
games and other content to get started
visit nordvpn.com Dr Mike remember
doctor is spelled out and try it
risk-free now with a 30 day money back
guarantee it's so easy and takes just
one click all right let's get back to
the games
oh oh that's that's vile
I don't think you can hang just solely
off your palms of your hands for that
long I think you'll tear through the
tissue I mean depending on how much you
weigh I guess
what are you doing does my guy not feel
pain he's just like chatting it through
remember the highest concentration of
nerves is in your hands your palms
that's going to be the most painful
possible injury
I know enough medicine to know that
there's not enough structural Integrity
inside your hand to allow 200 pounds to
hang off of it
oh he's already he's accelerating that
process
if he doesn't instantly die from massive
blood loss he's gonna die from a
bacterial infection full on sepsis
random green container
maybe look at the label B maybe look at
the directions for use the last thing I
want to have happen to you Ethan Winters
is the same thing that happened to Mark
Rober on the hot ones where he also
didn't read the label and ended up
spraying himself and swallowing the
medication that is not supposed to be
used as much as it was Nor swallowed
how did his hand grow back regenerative
potion
[Music]
oh he lost his arm unless he has a
tourniquet right now he dies in five
minutes although I will say there are
situations where if you get a really
clean cut of an artery it can constrict
so hard that it does cut off circulation
that is rare
why did the bleeding stop
oh he has the potion the the regrow
regrow limb potion
humans are not like that oh it was glue
the whole time you know we actually use
surgical glue to close wounds sometimes
but that's obviously ridiculous because
you're not gonna connect the nerves with
that surgical glue nor are you going to
connect the arteries and if you do
they're going to be blocked then the
hand is going to necross why am I
playing out this imaginary scenario like
it's a real medical situation oh yeah
because this is the YouTube channel
where I do that
okay waterboarding torture
this feeling of Suffocation creates a
level of air hunger that essentially
makes you want to give in to anything
that's why people do use it as a form of
torture in fact not to say this is the
same situation when we treat patients at
the end of their lives especially ones
who are on hospice we do give them a
significant prescription of morphine and
some people think that you're
accelerating their death by giving them
morphe the reason we give morphine in
these situations is not to accelerate
that it's to treat the symptom of air
hunger because that air hunger is
incredibly uncomfortable so imagine
you're weak because of blood loss
because the cancer won't let your lungs
fill up whatever is the reason for it
but you want air you can't get it no
matter what because of your physical
limitations morphine takes away the
feeling of that air hunger not just pain
does it also as a side effect shorten
life it may but that's not the reason we
give it
whoa okay the physics of this
is kind of unrealistic she's just kind
of flying around
with her hands tied behind her back does
she know how hard it is to move oh Angie
bit his ear off she might Tyson him
oh unless she bit is it carotid then
it's game over the high arterial
pressure system lots of blood loss death
in 30 seconds to a minute
that wasn't here you wouldn't die that
quickly from an ear to have two This
Groove is so tight all around
this looks scary oh no
oh no laser is it laser eye surgery
is this a penetrating laser a cooling
laser what's happening
isn't it going to the pupil the iris
razor
turns into a drill directly into the
pupil look that's massive eye trauma
right into the vitreous humor right into
the retina this is this is optimal logic
emergency we need to call for help stat
Dr glaucom flockin we need you
oh my God yeah lots of bleeding you know
we actually do a lot of injections into
eyes like it's one of the most common
procedures that eye doctors do to give
medications into the eye and if you numb
the eye and you go from the side it's
not a problem there might be a little
red dot but it's not a problem when you
get a needle into your eye if you get a
needle into your eye it really depends
where it goes is it a clean needle how
deep all these questions so it could be
something as simple as just like a
little bit of redness and irritation to
full-on blindness I like like you heard
of us or something
because they have
oh shotgun to the thigh slash shins
that's a zygomatic fracture if I've ever
seen one taking the butt of a gun
directly to your cheekbone all clear
he's out yeah and his sinuses are shot
my guy's Never Gonna breathe the same
tourniquet his leg
dude you're gonna drop it off no don't
do it don't you [__] move bro maybe
move and just let them shoot you like
honestly that's the better play you know
what they're about to do
so they're cutting off circulation to
his leg to keep him alive longer I'm
assuming for this torture that they're
about to inflict on him
oh whoa I mean he's gonna die
get up
go [__] get up um yeah he's he's he
had a few
blunt force traumas to everywhere and
potentially lost the limb
sounds like my man's got a tuberculosis
cough going on over here you got money
I mean before I start treating you
because I got a family I understand yeah
sure doesn't he have health insurance
what's wrong I mean what appeared to be
the symptoms squeezing weak fatigue
sweaty breathe
coarse breath sounds bilaterally with
that fake stethoscope you got
tuberculosis oh oh I wonder how they
diagnosed this because now we get like
X-rays and look for cavitations and
lungs so I'm curious how they did this
back in the day by the way tuberculosis
is a mean bacterial infection that's
found in the lungs but it can actually
spread to other parts of your body as
well
[Music]
this is this is honestly the most
ridiculous part I mean there's probably
a million more things I can comment on
this game but my guy flies from like 300
feet in the air and lands in 600 pieces
of hay and is like fine have you ever
seen the blow up things that they need
to put underneath buildings when people
jump off of buildings like those things
need to deflate and exert pressure out
and they're huge and this guy's like oh
look there's a wooden freaking Carriage
that I'm just gonna jump into
[Music]
okay what oh
is that a burn any thoughts on Mario
getting burned today uh he needs Dr
Mario
you know I'm a doctor in real life so
please never show these tick tocks to
your doctor click here to check those
out and once again huge thank you to
nordvpn for sponsoring this video as
always stay happy and healthy